maz what's going on brother how are you
i'm great man it's good to see you
good to see you man i love this setup i
never i've never been in here so this is
your first time huh it's my first time
man last time i saw you you and i were
doing stand up at the laugh factory i
had to
follow you and it was a nightmare you
know brendan nightmare
once i take down my pants and people
have seen that i'm just heartful
that's a small penis
they're still talking you're on stage
you're like yeah i got jokes that was a
small penis
you know it's funny you say that gosh
man well thanks man first of all
uh i i was looking i i scroll through
photos sometimes
and it was march 12th and it was
interesting because last year around
this time
you and i saw each other on a plane and
as i was uh i remember
i had all these dates lined up and
people were always like i was talking to
paul virzie and we're like
are you going to be doing your dates
we're like yeah because the government
hasn't said anything
and the government didn't say anything
it took like it took
the nba a private enterprise
to shut that [ __ ] down before we all
started shopping
seriously yes yes i remember i was on a
plane
i was headed to new orleans i'm on the
plane and it's when everything's
starting to get hectic
and i'm like are we i'm text my my age
i'm like are you sure i'm good to do
this
because like a theater of 800 people
he's like yeah you're good man you're
good
and then uh my brother who's my road
manager goes
hey bert just canceled i'm like bert
kreischer did
like bert just canceled he's in new
orleans same night different theater
different venue he just canceled like
something's going on here dude so i text
manager i'm like dude are you 100 sure
i'm good to go
and he goes well we're playing by air i
just got off the plane played by air
yeah i'm out
they see that's the part that's the
problem is and and we can go back and i
don't know what your guys politics are
it doesn't matter the point is
we look to our leadership to go
at some point to go listen this shit's
serious we're gonna lock that [ __ ] down
the problem
the problem is it wasn't clear like the
information from the top officials
whether it's
newsom even fauci yeah who you know
fauci
to trump to to our leaders it was just
like
you you had to kind of like shuffle
through all this [ __ ]
but we didn't it was like so but that's
important
but that's what we didn't know like
nothing was clear the point is look when
you come to my comedy show you're going
to count on me
jokes being funny i'm gonna deliver i'm
gonna have energy i'm there every night
i'm gonna do it there's no confusion
okay so we also
look to our cd cdc i did i've had a guy
on my podcast who is
uh um you know a journalist who was who
was
uh studying all the epidemiology and all
that stuff he'd done all the reporting
yeah he was he was trying to you know
tell us
an analogy he goes cdc is the new york
yankees
of disease control like meaning like
they are supposed to be the best of the
best
yes and so we look at you look at the
best of the best and you go
all right are we gonna lock it down or
not but it falls on two comics talking
and going you gonna do your dates this
weekend
i don't know i'm not sure how many
people could we had no idea
well the nation didn't either and there
was like well this state's locked down
this one's not that's what's crazy in
this restaurant not in this city look
dude
like wait i just want one blanket like
tell me what to do
but know your [ __ ] don't tell me wear
masks don't wear a mask straight up you
need to
listen again monday monday morning
quarterbacking but still you need to
have your leadership from the federal
government needs to step up and be like
yo
we're not sure what's going on but we're
just right now straight up let's just
cancel
for everybody cancel hey brendan cancel
you kids cause we don't know
moss can't see a gig we don't know we're
figuring this out yes as opposed to
leaving it up to us so you and i
march 12 were at the comedy store great
time and at the laugh factory
and it was interesting because they had
gone to the thing of like 50-person
capacity yep
that was what it was in the comments and
the factory both of them okay
and people it was funny because people
were all nervous nobody knew what's
going on it was like
and then and it got a laugh because you
go on stage i went on stage i was like
are we supposed to be here yeah and
they're all laughing i was like you guys
don't give a [ __ ] like nobody and and
like you said we had a great time i have
that picture of you and me just right
there
not knowing what's coming man who knew
who knew
but i think the other thing that was
confusing is especially even now it's
like
for us to look at the leaders and the
leadership in the government
and you know you can look at the
approval rating of our leadership our
government
it's so down because we don't trust it
because you see newsome yeah
it's like is it this serious because
he's in a restaurant right he didn't
shut down his
vineyard he's like he's out and about
yeah so i know he's shut down all the
small businesses but then he's okay
well what i do is i'm i'm a person of
like i err on the side of caution so i'm
sitting there going like all right even
if this guy
says shut it down then he goes to a
restaurant himself i go look this is
pretty legit like you you can look at a
fouchy and be like
you know people always argue well he
didn't say we're mass in the beginning
well you look at him and he goes well
the data was coming in number one number
two we didn't want everyone going and
taking the n95s the way they were taking
all the toilet paper
and then the medical people don't have
mass that's the other thing i say
our country tell us that but don't let
us
find that out second hand from like tmz
because it's like i
don't trust you but listen but listen
here's the problem and i i don't again i
don't know where you guys fall on it i
definitely am
left leaning when it comes to my
politics and i feel like there was a lot
of anti-science
in the previous administration to the
point where scott atlas shows up
and he's like let's just do her immunity
and then someone's like well
if you do the math that's like two three
million people got to die before we just
get there
without all of those one percent of
three million yeah whatever it is right
300 million yeah
so whatever it is so so i feel like
um um you know the the the problem was a
lack of leadership
and and that again goes back to look we
can't but here's my thing
you but lack of leadership 100 i'm with
you and it was super
deluded and there's like this weird gray
area which we're locked down but we
don't know why
we're wearing masks some aren't wearing
masks but if you tell me
if give give me a reason why and i'm on
board but if you just say do
this and don't give us a reason and i
don't trust you in the first place it's
hard to it's hard but see that's the
problem
because i think the left and right isn't
straight well listen the problem is what
you just said is
is when you find out things like when
you see newsome
at the restaurant you see pelosi getting
the hair thing done you go oh my god
like are
they taking it seriously or not but what
you just said you have
you guys are smart enough to be able to
look at
and be critical thinkers and go all
right you know what yes i wasn't
trusting it before now the data says
you know yeah obviously it's basic logic
stay far from each other the odds of you
getting that guy's spit in your face
are going to be diminished put a mask on
the odds are going to be diminished it's
just basic logic yes
and and the problem becomes where you're
right we have this skepticism in our
head
and now we're going like who's telling
the truth who's not but that goes back
to what i was saying
my number one issue with trump as
president
was a lot of people voted for him
because they were like we want an
outsider we want someone who doesn't we
don't want a politician we don't want
we want someone who comes from and i
said that's and i said in my in my
my netflix special my previous special i
was like this is the only
thing in the world where people go i
want an outsider you never go to get an
operation and go i want a guy who's
never done surgery
to operate on my eye yeah right yeah and
and so we see what happens when you
bring in an outsider because i don't
know about you guys but i'll be honest
with you listen i'm not saying biden is
perfect but i will tell you man ever
since these guys have come in
america's chilled out i've breathed
their sigh of relief i agree
dude first of all we were under four
years i feel like we were bombarded by
trump's again i don't care if you like
him or not you have to admit every
morning
he'd wake up 10 tweets 20 tweets so it
was like it was like the game tetris
it's unprofessional the the blocks are
coming and you're like oh my god
and i go these past two weeks i've been
so happy to wake up and just
listen to just just real news they're
like oh
there's global warming i'm like yes
there it is yeah you know
there's a pandemic yes we're gonna die
but like a lot of comics and like a lot
of those late night uh
hosts what are you gonna do now what are
you gonna do now
you know are you gonna still do trump
business no no listen like that's your
game
let me tell you something because again
as someone who's on the left and i'm an
iranian american i'm an immigrant right
and my mom first of all a lot of iranian
americans turned around and liked trump
including my own mother that was an
interesting one so it was funny because
when
trump when biden won i called my mom
like did you see he won and she's like
well
now what are you going to make jokes
about i was like you two mom you're
you're coming at me
right now but the truth is i listen man
i
i was doing jokes i i'm i'm i'm happy to
go back to talking about my kids yeah
i'm like
by the way biden's going to do [ __ ] that
we're going to make fun of right
yeah and people always say they always
go people ask me to go
trump must have been good for comedy
[ __ ] no because
two reasons number one he said so much
crazy [ __ ]
it was never you you could never keep up
with him right he'd say one thing i
remember he was like
little rocky man i got i needed a little
rocket man joke pocahontas i need a
pocahontas joke storm me down i need to
stormy daniel's joke
and you go on and on and on and you
can't keep up with the guy so that was
number one
and everyone's doing it and everyone's
doing it but you know you got your point
of view on it but it's like
as if you're a touring comedian if
you're not a late night
host who's got riding team and going
today trump said and let's go down it's
hard to keep up
if you're a comedian who's going to
spend a year working on your hour
and then go do that hour and you do that
hour and then people watch it they're
like wait when did trump say
rocket man oh that was before the timing
is on
and before it's done too hard to keep up
that's number one the second thing that
nobody talks about and i felt it
firsthand and i don't know brendan if
you ever talk
if you guys ever talk about um uh uh
trump in your stand-up or not but i stay
away from it i don't
i i'm very political because again
coming from immigrant background i'm
like i got to talk about this right if
it's your thing
yeah double down i have to and so and so
it was interesting because
as much as people go oh he was good for
comedy i realized once she's gone i
realized that i had a certain level of
anxiety
because people got so sensitive
to trump jokes trump supporters so
before trump became president when he
was just the host of the apprentice
i would do trump jokes people would
chuckle life goes on
once he starts running for president
starts saying some racist [ __ ] is
personal starts saying some other [ __ ]
people come on board and they go yeah i
love him he's saying what he's saying
what he he means what he means
yeah and then you do a joke and people
start yelling at you in the audience
so i i felt like there was a certain
level of anxiety any time i would
because the way i would do my show is i
would do like kid kid kid material
now i'm going to my trump jokes so i
would kind of like me too
put my toe in by going all right guys
i'm about to do
some trump jokes you know you all need
to calm the [ __ ] down
i'm not making fun of your grandmother
yeah my own mother's a trump supporter
i've had to deal with this [ __ ] so just
relax
and i'm gonna do some jokes about trump
and i might even have bison jokes just
just calm down yep and i swear to god
even when you do that sometimes
still they still get weird does this get
so that
causes anxiety for me like why is it as
a comedian in america
why is it as a comedian in america i'm
not i'm not in
you know some despotic country in some
you know some far-off land where they go
don't make fun of the king
yeah you're not north korea i'm not in
north korea right
i'm in the united states where we're
supposed to as an audience member you're
supposed to come and be like
you know that was you know i didn't find
that funny but i'm not going to yell i'm
not going to lose my mind
so i had that anxiety going the whole
time and i still like when i when i
slowly put my toe into the trump water
i'm still it's it's become a cult in a
way
in that it's fine to be a support
i love barack obama but you come and
tell me hey barack obama
uh under barack obama there was the the
most drone attacks
ever than any previous president i'd be
like you're right he wasn't perfect he
did some batches yeah whatever president
you side with
i can pick apart some of it it's just
that comes with the two and you gotta
and that's what america is about is we
should laugh at our
leader we can we can make fun of our
leaders why because we're supposed to
expose their hypocrisy whether it's
gavin newsom yes or nancy pelosi or
donald trump
we should be able to be like wait a
minute you're going to the restaurant
tell me and i can't go you going to the
restaurant
you know what i'm saying so as much as
people go oh what are you gonna talk
about
now he was you know he was good for
comedy i go man i feel the level of
anxiety that guy caused me
in my day-to-day and then even in
stand-up it's just it was nice it wasn't
worth it yeah how about that when i get
off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song